welcome back to this special edition of
the Ingram angle one of the most
divisive issues in America today is the
forced removal of historic statues while
some want to preserve our nation's
history
others say these figures are not worthy
of remembrance given their support of
slavery or the Confederacy case in point
a group of students at Hofstra
University on Long Island want Thomas
Jefferson his statue outside the Student
Center removed because our nation's
third president owned slaves and last
year the city of New Orleans removed
several Confederate statues here's what
New Orleans Democrat Mayor Mitch
Landrieu had to say about this issue
earlier today you can't change history
by taking a statue down you're just
moving it to another place these
particular monuments occupy prominent
places and reflect only four years of
New Orleans as 300 years history
crowding out all of the other history
joining me now for reaction is Fox News
correspondent at-large Geraldo Rivera
author of the Geraldo show a memoir and
with me here on set is Fox News
political analyst John O Caldwell all
right
Geraldo let's start with you on this
Mitch Landrieu has had a number of
statues removed in the dark of night and
these are statues that have been there
for a long time they're worth multi
million dollars and we don't even know I
guess where most of them are Petey
Beauregard other statues don't know
where they are they're just gone what's
your take on this is this the right way
to handle these historical monuments
well putting aside what's happening in
New Orleans and I really do like
mayor Landrieu I think that he's a very
thoughtful man I think his family has a
real roots real real cred when it comes
to New Orleans and Louisiana history
generally speaking but remember Laura I
resigned from my fellowship at Calhoun
College at Yale University a year or so
ago when they changed the name taking
John C Calhoun's name off the college
and naming it for a more contemporary
person I fear when history starts being
rewritten constantly through the prism
of political correctness and
contemporary thought that we risk
cutting ourselves off from our
now I absolutely get that slavery this
abomination is different than a lot of
things that happen in political life
this is something like the Holocaust
that can't be forgiven but I think that
to try and continually rewrite history
Jefferson was a slave owner so is George
Washington what will happen when the
entire first third of our history is is
cut off or in some way covered up Laura
John
well there's levels as I see it do you
have the Confederate statues ones of
generals and if you look at the history
of the generals
most of those guys they were military
generally speaking and that was pretty
much it so you got these statues in
public squares of individuals who fought
to really divide our country and when
you look at it from that perspective I
think he gives a greater degree of
understanding why statues like that [ __ ]
really be in museums now when it comes
to somebody like Thomas Jefferson for
example he's much more than a slave
owner that was a past sin of his but
this is somebody who created had a hand
in creating a declaration of
independence and he said all men are
created created equal in addition to
that he was a president he was a
governor he was the Secretary of State
so this is an individual I think that we
can celebrate although he did have past
sins these other individuals however
their past sins was the majority of
their career from the view point of
having a competitor stamp et Beauregard
general Beauregard is one of those
generals who did so much after the war
he helped build schools for minority
children and he did so much work to try
to bring the fabric of the community
together I mean there he was a beloved
person post-war so yes sins of slavery
horrific mm-hmm an entire lifespan maybe
not so much with everyone and I agree
with her Aldo that painting every
historical figure that was living in the
south at the time and might have even
fought in the war with this brush of put
him away take him away in the middle of
the night put it somewhere we don't even
know I think that does not serve us all
all that well and look I'm not a black
person I don't know how it feels to walk
by one of these statues and
you're told this person hated you and
didn't it didn't think you were a real
person I can't imagine that but I do
think people who specially worked for a
reconstruction or forgiveness for
bringing and healing the country
especially those people I think we're on
a real slippery slope if we start saying
like and look these Hofstra students
they're serious they were serious at
Princeton about Woodrow Wilson a great
internationalist Democrat hero now we'll
do Woodrow Wilson has to go off the
Wilson Center this is what one of the
Hofstra students said on Fox News the
right to peaceful protest and assembly
is that the core of our democracy
Hofstra supports our students right to
engage in peaceful demonstrations about
issues that matter to them we look
forward to continuing civil exchange of
ideas on the subject that's what their
statement was to Fox News but it looks
like groups of students mobilized at
Princeton University not successfully
yet but I think it's a matter of time
before Thomas Jefferson gets put in that
same place as robert e lee who passed
american presidents including FDR hailed
is one of the greatest generals we've
ever had one of the greatest Christian
gentlemen we've ever had that's FDR's
commemoration of robert e lee so this is
a wild territory Rhiannon I don't know
where it ends guys and I would have to
disagree with you I think it's a
slippery slope if we're continue to put
these individuals these Confederate
generals in similar categories as Thomas
Jefferson they are not in similar
categories this Thomas Jefferson you
have individuals who really founded our
country Christian principles you talk
about robert e lee democrats who look to
destroy the fabric of our very country
and yes african-americans he knows his
wife african-americans see this for a
problem see this as a problem because
you see many that celebrate this and not
put it in his proper categorization so
if you want to put it into museum by all
means it we can't erase our history and
I understand that certainly not but we
should be celebrating it in public
squares and allowing for people that
think that it was nothing wrong with
should we rename Washington DC haha you
know Laura I just going back to oh yeah
it's not too far from here
yeah I get it I got a KERS of land john
c calhoun in the 1950s was voted one of
the five greatest senators in american
history by a senate an elite senate
panel that included john f kennedy so
senator kennedy was one of those who
picked John Calhoun is one of the great
Senate that was in the 1950s my fear is
that as contemporary mores and values
and who's in and who's out change will
continually be a racing history will
have to be written in pencil rather than
in ink and I don't I don't think that
that gets anyone anywhere but I will say
this much there was a time in this
country at the beginning of the of the
reaction to reconstruction the beginning
of Jim Crow where statues were erected
specifically to stick it to black people
to let them know who who was still boss
and who is subordinate those statues I
think when you you know they may have
the facade is a historic monument but
the real purpose is a racialist social
statement rather than a historic
remembrance and I think that you can
look at them it's easy to find their
provenance their history and determine
how you feel about them based on that
all right guys a great segment